New York's Deputy Police Commissioner
for intelligence and counterterrorism
John Miller is with us so John what
security steps are we taking here at
home in response to this attack overseas
so Nora that started last night we have
an NYPD post in Australia we have a very
close relationship with the police in
New Zealand so this information was
coming in to us in real time and very
quickly we identified we're gonna have
to increase police presence around
mosques around houses of worship we're
gonna have to have roving patrols our
house of worship cars that are assigned
to the precinct to keep that liaison
with religious institutions are going
out and making contact you'll see a
public message of reassurance we got
calls already this morning Friday
prayers is very important in Islam they
said that it's packed at that time what
do you see John when you look at this
attack what I see is a lot of
similarities to in terms of tactics you
can see that the neo-fascist groups
white supremacists are borrowing from
the ISIS playbook in this attack you see
the phenomenon that we coined the phrase
in the NYPD dying live this was an Isis
tactic where they said if you're going
to do a mass casualty attack you know
you should livestream it over social
media we've seen we've seen them
adopting many of the atactic that the
the terrorist tactics you would see and
things like Isis is Rumia magazine or Al
Qaeda's magazines in terms of
instruction so John tell us where in
your thinking the threat is from white
nationalists we also know of the Coast
Guard member who was plotting along
exactly the same lines where is that in
your threat matrix well I mean you saw
the attack on the mosque in in Canada an
active shooter attack you see the
Pittsburgh synagogue attack you see some
of the propaganda and online forums
there so this is something that we
monitor very carefully it's something
that has been emergent we're seeing an
increase in the propaganda
again when we look at their propaganda
they are borrowing propaganda techniques
from other terrorist groups so this is
something we watch very closely
you are telling us so you know the
police commissioner new zealand quite
well walk walk us through what he's
doing right now to investigate this well
Mike Mike Bush has three you know major
areas first he's got to deal with crime
scene families victims and public
messaging he's got to deal with the
investigation which then goes very
quickly to the questions we've been
working with them on overnight which is
who is this offender what is his
background what is connection to other
people are there other people out there
is this a one-off attack or is it part
of a series and then dealing with a
terribly complex crime scene on that
point CBS News has just learned that law
enforcement in New Zealand says that the
suspect is claiming because he is in
custody right now
there are other planning attacks on
mosques in New Zealand in the works
is he boasting what do they do about
this well you have to take everything
like that seriously I'm gonna be very
careful not to speak to New Zealand that
could be a scare tactic that could be
accurate or inaccurate you know we're
very early in this our work overnight
with with New Zealand and our colleagues
over there was what's the information
you have on identities has there been
traveled to the United States is there
are there associates in the United
States what information can we push back
to you in New Zealand that would be
helpful so far this is important you
know what we see is no significant u.s.
Nexus keep digging and more importantly
from our individual perspective no Nexus
to New York City so we've been talking
to religious institutions that we're
talking today about we have an event
should we cancel it should we and we're
gonna provide police resources
reassurance protection high-profile
resources and we tell everybody you know
you don't cancel anything otherwise
otherwise they win yeah but it's hard to
take that thinking though when you see
something that's horrific
the point I was going to make the fact
is that they have a suspect in custody
he was alive gives I would think
authorities a great advantage here
well it does because now you have
somebody who you can talk to yeah
somebody who I mean based on the
manifesto based on the writings that he
carried on him and his equipment someone
who seems to want to have a message does
the fact that bombs were reportedly
diffused from his car raised the the
height and heightened the the security
threat that's a factor we've seen before
a lot of these attackers go back to
Andres Brevik and that attack where they
try to exceed the casualty rate the
equipment you saw explosives there they
tend to mimic each other so I would say
that's going to be a non surprise here
alright John Miller good to see you
thank you so much for being here I know
on a very busy morning we appreciate it
thanks for having me